en un vídeo anterior vimos el mecanismo
de la reacción de adición de alumnos de
hidrógeno a de llenos conjugados en este
vídeo lo que vamos a hacer es ver cómo
controlar esa reacción pero para saber
cómo controlar esa reacción necesitamos
recordar el mecanismo de la reacción en
esa reacción vimos que estos electrones
de aquí los electrones del enlace doble
entre el carbono 1 y el carbono 2
funcionaron como una base y se llevaron
un protón de nuestro haluro de hidrógeno
y entonces esos electrones se fueron a
formar este enlace de aquí y agregamos
este protón en el carbono número 1
porque eso hace que el carbó catión se
forme en el carbono número 2 y de esa
forma es un carbó catión alico
estabilizado por la resonancia y ya que
estamos en esta situación pues teníamos
varias posibilidades y una de ellas es
que el alumno actúe como un núcleo filo
y haga un ataque núcleo físico a este
carbó catión y entonces se agrega el
halógeno en el carbono número 2 ya
habíamos agregado el protón en el
carbono número 1 y entonces tenemos un
abductor a ducto
12 la otra posibilidad que teníamos aquí
nosotros sabemos que esta molécula está
estabilizada por resonancia
entonces puede ser que estos electrones
de este enlace doble se muevan a este
lugar de aquí entre los carbonos 2 y 3
y entonces como le quitamos un enlace a
este carbono ahora este carbono es un
kart vocación y entonces puede llegar el
alumno que formamos en el primer paso de
la reacción puede llegar el alumno y
hacer un ataque núcleo físico a éste
carbó catión de aquí entonces lo que
obtenemos es esta molécula de aquí donde
agregamos un protón en el primer carbono
ese fue el primer paso y después
agregamos un halógeno en el cuarto
carbono
y es que lo que obtenemos es el aductor
ducto
14 así es que tengo el aductor 1 o 2 y
el adulto 14 y de hecho puedo controlar
cuál de estos dos productos es el
producto orgánico mayor en mi reacción y
para hacer eso lo que tengo que hacer es
pensar en la estabilidad de los al que
nos producidos así es que si tengo que
pensar en la estabilidad del viaducto 12
entonces tengo que pensar en qué tan
sustituido está el doble enlace así es
que vale la pena dibujar todos los
hidrógenos aquí tenemos nuestros tres
hidrógenos tenemos tres hidrógenos y
claramente se ve que tenemos un solo
grupo r entonces este al que no es mono
sustituido por otro lado pensando en la
estabilidad de la ducto 14 tenemos aquí
el doble enlace
dibujamos los hidrógenos
y podemos ver que tiene dos grupos cr
entonces es de
sustituido y como sabemos como hemos
visto en otros vídeos los al que nos dé
sustituidos son más estables que los
monos substituidos ok
más más estable
estable que el al que no mono sustituido
entonces este es menos estable
menos estable
table que esté así es que bajo algunas
circunstancias
este va a ser el producto mayor ya estas
circunstancias le llamamos control
termodinámica
terol termo
termo dinámico de
mico
y de lo que estoy hablando es de agregar
un poco de calor si le agregamos calor a
esta reacción
la reacción está sucediendo bajo control
termodinámica y por lo tanto el producto
más estable es el que va a ganar
entonces en este mecanismo si agregamos
calor el calor adicional va a dar
suficiente energía como para que este
enlace se mueva para acá y elkar
vocación de aquí a la izquierda se mueva
a hacer el carb ocasión de aquí en la
derecha y entonces el allure o ataque en
la posición de carbono número 4
obteniendo así como producto en mayor
cantidad el adulto 14 entonces si le
agregas un poco de calor a la reacción
todo está en equilibrio y vas a obtener
el producto más estable bajo control
termodinámica el cual es el aductor 14
ahora si lo que quieres es obtener el
aductor 12 entonces tienes que hacer las
cosas un poco diferente que en lugar de
agregar calor lo que tienes que hacer s
las condiciones de tu reacción entonces
si lo en frías por ejemplo a cero grados
vas a formar producto 12 bajo lo que se
llama control cinético
control
control cinético
cinético
y el control simétrico en la química en
general se refiere a la velocidad de la
reacción aunque qué tan rápido sucede la
reacción y el adulto 12 de hecho es el
producto que más rápidamente se forma y
podemos ver por qué sucede eso
observando el mecanismo de reacción a
guys y nos vemos hasta arriba en el
primer paso donde formamos nuestro luro
y nuestro carbó catión alico en nuestro
alumno se forma aquí justo a la derecha
de la molécula el hidrógeno se va con el
carbono número 1 y como el alumno está
aquí a la derecha muy cerca del carbono
número 2 entonces puede muy rápidamente
hacer este ataque núcleo hill y ccoo
recrear aquí el año en el 1 está muy
cerca del kart vocación pero si pensamos
en el aductor 14 allí tenemos el año na
luro aquí este hidrógeno se acaba de
enlazar con este carbono y el anillo na
luro sigue estando del lado derecho de
la molécula pero ahora el carb ocasión
fue a dar hasta acá entonces este año un
alumno tiene que recorrer una mayor
distancia para llegar y hacer el ataque
núcleo físico a éste carbó catión y si
no hay suficiente energía en el sistema
entonces el avión allure o simplemente
no va a llegar hasta acá así es que esto
se trata de la proximidad del núcleo a
filo al electro filo y como en el
ejemplo de la izquierda el núcleo filo
está súper cerca del electro filo se va
a agregar mucho más rápido que en este
ejemplo entonces el producto adulto 12
es el más rápido en formarse entonces si
mantienes todas las cosas bien enfriada
no hay suficiente energía para formar el
aductor 14 y el aductor 12 es el
producto mayor bajo control cinético
ahora vamos a ver un ejemplo de cómo
podemos controlar el producto de una
reacción de adicción de un día no
conjugado voy a dibujar un día no
conjugado aquí voy a empezar con 1 exc
no tenemos aquí un ciclo hexano y le voy
a poner dos enlaces dobles uno aquí y
otro aquí ahora sí ya es un lleno y un
grupo metilo para acá y además vamos a
hacer que esta molécula sea una molécula
simétrica entonces tiene otro grupo
metilo por aquí entonces aquí tenemos a
nuestro vino conjugado y simétrico y
vamos a hacer que reaccione con pues
digamos que con ácido clorhídrico
entonces si queremos numerar los
carbonos de esta cadena como es una
molécula simétrica no importa por qué
lado empezamos entonces digamos que este
es el carbono 1 2 3 y 4 así es que
tenemos a un día no conjugado simétrico
y lo vamos a hacer reaccionar con ácido
clorhídrico pero lo vamos a hacer
reaccionar de dos formas distintas en la
primera forma vamos a mantener una
temperatura de cero grados
entonces si pensamos acerca del
mecanismo el primero paso del mecanismo
es que estos electrones peak actúen como
una base y se lleven a un protón
entonces llegan estos electrones speed y
se llevan a este protón de aquí y
entonces estos electrones se van con el
cloro por lo que por aquí lo que nos
queda se ve así
y lo que tenemos que pensar en este
momento es ese protón en cuál de los dos
carbonos se va a quedar y pensamos y
entonces sabemos que el protón se va a
quedar en el carbono número uno ok
porque eso permite que el carbón catión
se quede en la posición número dos que
este de aquí ahora va a ser un kart
vocación y queremos que este sea el kart
vocación porque está al lado de este
enlace doble y entonces es un kart
vocación al lille y ccoo los cuales son
más estables y en el siguiente paso de
mi reacción el unión cloruro que se
forma que annie
el hurón con su carga negativa
actúa como un núcleo filo y como las
cosas están muy frías el cloruro se
queda justo aquí en el lugar donde este
enlace le quitó un protón entonces éste
nyon cloruro está muy cerca de este kart
vocación al bíblico y lo ataca en esta
posición 2 y entonces
todavía tenemos un enlace doble por aquí
y un grupo metilo aquí en el segundo
carbono
otro grupo metilo en el carbono 3 y
ahora también tenemos un cloro aquí en
el carbono 2 entonces este es el 12
adulto que adoptó 12 que es el adulto
mayor porque estamos bajo control
simétrico ok enfriamos todo y entonces
vamos a obtener el aductor 12 como el
adulto en mayor cantidad si hiciéramos
esta reacción otra vez pero cambiaremos
las condiciones de la reacción ok vamos
a hacer que vuelvan a reaccionar el bien
o conjugado con el ácido clorhídrico
pero esta vez le vamos a agregar calor
esta vez estamos bajo control
termodinámico entonces el primer paso de
este mecanismo de reacción es
exactamente el mismo ok los electrones y
funcionan como una base y se llevan a un
protón y el carbó catión del resultado
es el kart vocación al licor entonces el
protón se agrega en el carbono número 1
y el carbó catión está en el carbono
número 2 igual que en la otra reacción
ahora como estamos bajo control
termodinámica sabemos que aquí vamos a
obtener otra estructura de resonancia
entonces
tenemos aquí un grupo metilo otro grupo
metilo un hidrógeno y en esta estructura
de resonancia este enlace doble se va a
mover para estar entre los carbonos 2 y
3 monkeys y escribimos los números otra
vez este es el carbono 1 2
4 entonces el doble enlace se mueve para
estar entre los carbonos 2 y 3 se mueve
por aquí y como al carbono número 4 le
acabamos de quitar un enlace entonces
ese es el cargo que tiene y nuestra
unión cloruro estaba por aquí
originalmente
con sus 8 electrones y su carga negativa
y el año en cloruro va a actuar como un
núcleo filo pero esta vez tiene un largo
camino que recorrer para llegar al kart
vocación en la posición 4 sin embargo
ahorita no importa porque estamos bajo
control termodinámica y entonces nuestro
mayor producto
va a ser el aductor 14 gay y el cloro se
va a agregar por aquí aquí se agrega un
protón y aquí se agregó el cloro
entonces este es el aductor 14 y este es
nuestro ducto mayor porque es el más
estable ya que cuando estamos bajo
control termodinámico tu producto mayor
va a ser el producto más sustituido
porque es más estable y este producto de
aquí este atrás sustituido que es más
estable que el aductor 12 si aumentamos
el calor en la reacción entonces hemos
visto cómo podemos controlar las
reacciones de adición de los conjugados
simplemente cambiando la temperatura en
la que sucede la reacción